let's go on to our next bullet which is
metrics now of course today's episode is
about fundraising and you know metrics
seem to play a big part in this yeah I
mean it's it's a question that we get
from founders a lot and you know what
what are the two of you seeing what kind
of growth and metrics are investors
looking for for let's say a seed or a
Series A yeah so a few different primary
metrics that I think most investors will
look at and so the number one is
typically revenue and so the question is
you know how fast does that revenue need
to be growing so the number that we
typically see is you know 10 15 20
percent the the higher you get to 20%
and the closer you get to 20 percent and
above is typically the the metric that a
month over month growth yes I made
10,000 this month for January in
February I'm a 12 and then in March I'm
a 20% of 12 which is 420 414 I'm about
15 whatever so that's not easy to do
correct that Nets out to what three or
four percent week over week and why are
investors obsessed with this percentage
growth at an early stage company sure so
I think it goes back to the point we
were talking about earlier which is you
know is this a venture scale business so
if you're going to get to 100 million in
revenue and in seven years the growth
needs to be almost unnaturally fast and
so this is the type of these the early
signal of that is this fast growth at
the early stage I think where you need
to be careful though is if you are
growing too fast and I think investors
will also look at additional metrics so
I think one of the things that you
typically will talk about with founders
what is that other metric that that we
can track alongside revenue so whether
that's you know engagement or you know
something along those lines so what do
you think you know alongside revenue
what do you typically recommend a
founder to to track so depending on if
they are an enterprise software company
a marketplace
a consumer product these are three very
different categories so in a marketplace
you might look at both sides of the
marketplace and how many participants
there are which would drive what people
call the quiddity in a marketplace so in
a marketplace like uber or Airbnb you
have drivers and riders and hosts and
guests well if you were Airbnb in the
early days and you said look we're
adding week over week you know fight
we're growing 5% on our base of hosts
every week and 20 percent
month-over-month yeah we had a hundred
hosts in January we had a twenty hosts
almost one a day or one every business
day in February be pretty impressive
right you found somebody with an extra
bedroom or an extra apartment who wants
to rent it you on-boarded them I mean
that's hard to do so that's the supply
side and obviously the demand side how
did you get new customers did you do all
the growth tricks for that so just
watching the nut and then with consumer
apps daily active users weekly active
users monthly active users and then
cohort analysis but you can look all
that up online but there's a whole
framework there and then there's a
framework that's been established and
none of this by the way 10 years ago
sitting here in Silicon Valley nobody
had these frameworks so it's becoming a
science startups that you know give a
lot of credit to someone like Eric Ries
who made it into a bit of a science and
then also people at slack and Yammer
really figured out how to make SAS also
Jason Lemkin from SAS sir they really
made SAS into a bit of a science so it
used to be alchemy or a little bit of
magic right product magic Steve Jobs
would just say here's the new product
and now it's more science so the science
in marketplaces is about building up the
volume on both sides so that you have
liquidity for consumers DLE active users
retention cohort analysis of the people
who signed up in January how many used
it in March of the February users how
many used it in March etcetera and then
when you go over to SAS there's this
thing churn turn means I quit left and
so that's the negative thing to look at
if you're earning 20% of your users that
means every five months you have to
replace your entire user base or more
right so it's faster because it's 20% in
month three of us much
while number so it's compounding in the
wrong way
so churn is one issue and then on the
other side the positive side landing and
expanding which is the reverse of churn
there's a buzzword for that what's the
buzz word for that negative churn
negative churn yes is yeah I knew it
would come
negative Church yeah explain what
negative churn is yeah so it's it's
actually that the your customers instead
of decreasing month over month an
existing customer base will actually
spend more with you every month which is
how is that possible so I mean I know
the most common example the most common
example is you've got a sales product
that you sell on a per seat so each
individual sales force outreach yep
something whatever mix Mac something
like that and so you have a you know a
team that uses it perhaps a team of 10
start using it and then the next month
you add another team of five that's
using it so now the the product that's
the same customer that's right at the
same cost so the expansion the land and
expand the expansion in the customers
that love it is greater than the people
quitting that's right it's pretty pretty
easy so I think those are the things on
metrics I look for I think it's
important here also to look at vanity
metrics and why they're not important
what what are some of the things we see
Ashley from founders that they put in
their decks because I think they're
looking to fill space but that actually
investors don't care about I mean I
would say although it certain be helpful
but like social media followers
especially when it's not really
significant I mean it's just you know
we're growing our social media and if
they're not if those social media
followers aren't translating to engage
users yeah that doesn't matter
yeah vanity metric vanity that's vanity
it doesn't yeah it doesn't visitors to
our website yeah these things could
matter if your business was we use
Instagram Mars or sales channel and
every thousand followers we get we sell
a hundred dollars more in subscriptions
for a calm calm you could maybe tie that
together but sure just the growth of it
generally we do see that index where
they're like our traction is amazing
we've increased the number of readers to
our blog and it's like
are you a blog company no where where
Khadem is coming it doesn't matter you
think getting press is another one that
we see really commonly you know cut off
orbs right up got a you know 30 under 30
you know those 40 under 40 50 over 50
yeah yeah yeah those sorts of patting
yourself on the back for those things I
would I would also say in the deck when
they include the logo of previous
company so their team their founding
team you have an an Apple logo on there
well I I know of a particular company
where they put that on there for their
founding team and he worked at an Apple
store but he was he was an Apple
employee so he has got the Apple logo
which I mean is a little bit of
stretching the truth but I mean it can
it can turn into sort of this vanity
thing where people think they have to
have they need to hire people that have
this background just so their deck looks
nice for yeah it is in some cases
credibility building if you're if you
were the person at Apple who managed the
App Store and now you're going to
another company that is putting apps in
the App Store or has a collection of
apps is like oh wow you know how the App
Store works or you worked on Apple's
podcasting effort and now you went to
work for gimlet media it's like Oh
gimlet media got a podcasting person to
work on their team I think they did have
somebody from Apple if I remember I met
somebody at an event that could be
meaningful but this is a very important
moment I think in this episode which is
you just caught somebody in not fraud
but bending of the truth this is super
dangerous yes and on that slippery slope
it's a slippery slope
and when you start bending reality like
this I'm not saying you're gonna wind up
like Elizabeth Holmes and Darren O's
which is the sort of like fraud example
but that could just eliminate you from
an investor ever investing hmm because
they will ask you if you put the Apple
logo what did you do at Apple or if you
said you're a Ted speaker and you were a
TEDx Albuquerque no offense to
Albuquerque I got a big following there
but I had people who put their where a
TED speaker and I was like
oh I was at Ted last year it was like oh
no I was at Ted addicts Albuquerque it's
like what long you know you're sort of
the expectation was so high and it went
down let's address I don't want them
raise money I don't want to turn on
revenue yet and we're focused on
technology we've had two companies go to
the syndicate recently that
overperformed
will perform really well that were just
pure technology plays yes didn't have
revenue traction what do you think
matters there because if there isn't
revenue traction and you're on a
two-year technology bill because it's
hard tech AI or something like that a
developer tool whatever how do you clear
market in that situation yeah and that
will actually lead me to a question that
I've had for you after this but so
founder is hugely important when you
don't have revenue you have to believe
in the founder and we're founders found
or founders yes a founding team yeah
that they are experts in the space that
typically they've they're not first-time
founders that doesn't certainly exclude
someone who is but that that helps their
so their background helps having
investors on their cap table big-name
investors whether that's a you know VCS
or seed or you know angels yeah that can
help validate a person it certainly
helped validate a person but yet Laura
largely it's it's the team yeah and how
well they can describe their company to
people who are non-technical I mean I
really think that that it's it's how you
can if you can bring it down to a
fifth-grade reading level which is you
know the average reading level of
Americans it's you know it can be very
very helpful not not ever engineer can
do that got it so when you're explaining
the business the high art is being able
to explain a complicated tech business
to investors who maybe don't have depth
in that space if you're if you're gonna
do it you had a question for me yeah
well about in that same you know
pre-revenue when you're looking at a
consumer product where's the tipping
point of we don't have any revenue yet
but this is the number of users of
engaged users we have and not only for
angels because at that point you're
you're still really investing in the
founder
but for a VC yeah I've heard 10 million
monthly users is the new bogie that's
like the new baseline 10 million monthly
active users Mouse is what people think
of series a starting - which if you had
different users everyday which you
wouldn't want but let's just say you
divide that by 10 to get to your that's
a million daily active users or 500,000
that's a lot no I think seed would occur
at 10 to 20 percent of that number sorry
I think a million users a month which
might be a hundred thousand a day would
clear the seed market tomorrow what are
you what are your thoughts if we put
numbers to it in 2019 because you might
be watching this in 2029 yeah I would
agree with the number I think growth
rate is also very important the velocity
yeah so you know where were you 30 days
ago where were your 60 days ago where
are you 90 days ago and I think in
consumer what you really want to see is
actually an acceleration of growth so
not and I started starting to taper as
you get to these higher numbers can can
be concerning as well you already know
that Zendesk is the world's greatest
customer support platform but what you
may not know is that they have a range
of products now they've evolved as a
company they've been adding a ton of
features studying their customers that's
us you and me and they've added a bunch
of products under the umbrella
Zendesk suite which is a simple yet
powerful solution to make it easy for
you to manage your customer
relationships and it includes an
integrated customer support system a
knowledge base or all the informations
in one place live chat because all these
young kids they want to chat even me I'm
48 I want to chat I don't want to talk
to somebody on the phone I don't want to
do email I want to chat it's easier easy
breezy and call center so with all of
these support channels connected you're
going to have the conversations you do
with your customers be seamless you're
not going to lose any important
discussions and make your company kind
of lose credibility with your important
customers in their moment of need right
and your agents will be wildly more
productive and all of that information
will be shared across your companies for
product development people or the CEO
and the c-suite they're all gonna
understand what's going on on the
frontlines finally you will be able to
scale your business without needing to
hire a bunch of people and that's really
what this is about it's about making
your customer support team Bionic making
them superheroes and they need to have
the Zendesk weed in order to do that and
here's the thing it's flat rate pricing
and you're not gonna believe the offer I
can't believe the offer
Zendesk this is your call to action
you're not gonna believe it
it's literally I think the best offer
I've ever read on their Zendesk comp
slash twist and you will get a free full
year if you're a startup they're
defining startup as Series B or earlier
and under a hundred employees or case
terms and conditions apply obviously but
you're gonna get the full product for
free for a full year this is an
incredible deal I don't know how long
they're gonna do it for it but Zendesk
wants to capture that early part of the
market here they want to get you when
you have two to a hundred employees and
you're gonna they're gonna do that by
giving you the software free which is
amazing you get the software for free
for a year
Zendesk comm slash twist Zendesk comm
slash twist
great job Zendesk on the offer i really
appreciate it ok let's get back to this
amazing episode